how's it going everybody Jason Silva
here hope everybody's having a beautiful
day so I recently returned from an
incredible experience at this year's CES
2018 that's the Consumer Electronics
Show where the world's greatest brands
showcased their most astounding products
now I was a special guest of wow way for
the launch of their new mate 10 Pro
flagship smartphone which is an
astounding device that in many ways is
the embodiment of something that I talk
about all the time
technological wizardry as the embodiment
of human creativity as the
literalization
of human imagination in the world now
this flagship smartphone the may 10 Pro
has one of the world's most powerful
mobile a is in fact artificially
intelligent algorithms assist the lake
camera in creating images that are some
of the most astounding photos you've
ever taken on your smartphone aside from
the fact of course of this device that
you can carry in your pocket today the
mate 10 Pro is a million times cheaper a
million times smaller and a thousand
times more powerful than what used to be
a supercomputer that was half a building
in size 40 years ago consider the
astounding technological progress that
we have achieved as a species consider
something that embodied with by example
with the huawei mate 10 pro a smartphone
like this in your pocket today in a
rural part of the world that's a young
person in Africa equipped with one of
these or a young person in China
equipped with one of these or a young
person in America equipped with the may
10 Pro has better communications
technology in their pocket then a head
of state had 25 years ago one of the
other amazing amazing features of the
huawei mate 10 pro is a real-time AI
powered object recognition functionality
so that essentially when you take a
photograph these AI powered algorithms
can identify the objects on the screen
they know exactly what you're taking a
picture of and therefore adjust the
color adjust the contrast and adjust all
these other variables that make whatever
you're taking a picture of come up
infinitely sharper and in
finnaly better so how does that change
what becomes possible for individuals
how do you use a smartphone like the
made 10 pro to extend your creativity in
the world to impact the world in a
positive way to become an entrepreneur
to extend your imagination to transcend
the boundaries of your creativity
equipped with a device that as arthur c
clarke once wrote any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic
now I'm honored to have been invited as
a special guest influencer for huawei's
astounding mate 10 Pro launched at CES I
was given one of these phones I was
gifted one of these phones and invited
to experience the launch to experience
the celebration of this kind of
innovation and you know wha way has made
some significant dents in the
marketplace they are the world's number
three phone manufacturer as of this
moment and hopefully American consumers
will become ever more familiar with the
brand because the more choice consumers
have the better and these guys are
giving other manufacturers a run for
their money so I want to thank huawei
for inviting me to be a part of this
launch to sort of join in the
celebration of evermore disruptive and
powerful technological scaffoldings
which I believe these smartphones are
not to mention the fact that it's got an
insanely amazing battery life I think
I've had the phone on for four days and
it still has like 49 percent battery so
thank you Wow way for this if you guys
aren't familiar with the May 10 Pro you
must check it out it's a wonderful
example of disruptive innovation and
technological wizardry as they say as I
imagine so it becomes and this is the
very essence of magic